games are kind of microcosm of the
outside world that's why games were
invented that's why humans find it fun
to play there's a rich history of
computer tackling board games
it started with games like backgammon
drafts and then finally there was deep
blue in 97 that'd be Kasparov at chess
which was obviously a huge watershed
moment for game AI since then the really
big remaining sort of Holy Grail if you
like has been go in chess a number of
possible moves about 20 for the average
position and go it's about 200 another
way of viewing the complexity of go is
that the number of possible
configurations of the board is more than
the number of atoms in the universe if
you ask a great go player why they play
the particular move sometimes they'll
just tell you it felt right so you can
the one way you can think of it is that
go is a much more intuitive game whereas
chess is a much more logic based game
the alphago is our program to actually
try and crack go we played the European
champion Fenway and a five-game match we
have an estimate how strong a program is
but of course you never know when you
play a human player they do all sorts of
very interesting creative things that
your programs not necessarily do so
there's always an unknown when we play
the further game I lose I think he was a
bit stunned off to the first game and I
think he was unsure as to whether he
hadn't prepared enough or whether the
program was really strong well I think
after first again maybe he don't like
fight in like play slowly so it's why we
begin the second game I fight
I see are maybe I'm right
it's why for another game I fight all
the time
no it's a completely
but I lose all my game
alphago won five nil which is the first
time ever a program has been a
professional player
the way I see where we are now is that
we've beaten the European champion now
and the next step for us is to try and
challenge the legendary play at least at
all you can think of as the Roger
Federer of go we always used to talk
about what if we could eventually crack
go and have a program that could be the
world champion then we must have
invented some generic general-purpose
algorithm so maybe we're on the cusp of
all of them and we're very excited about
it but it is just one a rung on the
ladder towards solving artificial
intelligence